the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon and a song of ice and fire
update video well my friends i have one
hell of an update for you in this video
as a matter of fact this has to be one
of the biggest announcements i have ever
seen it looks like i might be making
videos about westeros for the rest of my
life
now for those of you that don't know
george rr martin revealed a lot of new
information about all the different
things he has been working on for hbo as
well as himself in his new not a blog
update he goes over just about
everything which has me very excited for
the future of a song of ice and fire let
me show you what he said since there is
so much information to go over let's get
started right away he said i look around
and i don't know where last year went i
blinked and it was gone not a year that
i'm going to mourn much any more than
the year before a global pandemic so
many of my friends died as well as
celebrities of all sorts it was a year
best forgotten i did however get a lot
of work done an enormous amount of work
if i'm honest i seem to have an enormous
number of things in development
now i'm not complaining i like working i
like writing editing and producing there
is nothing i like better than
storytelling i know i know for many of
you out there only one of those actually
matter
i am sorry for you they all matter to me
yes of course i am still working on the
winds of winter i have stated that a
hundred times in a hundred venues having
to restate that endlessly is just
worrisome i made a lot of progress on
wins in 2020 and less in 2021 but less
is not none
the world of westeros the world of a
song of ice and fire is my number one
priority and will remain so until that
story is told
but westeros has become bigger than the
winds of winter or even a song of ice
and fire
okay now let me stop for a second right
here now i will say after reading this
section of the update i did not get the
sense that we will be getting the wins
of winner anytime soon the fact that he
is even still writing the wins of winner
is insane as i'm sure most of you know
by now he has been writing that novel
for over a decade already and after
reading what he just said it almost
sounds like his writing on the wins of
winner is actually slowing down he said
he got a lot done in 2020 but he got
even less done last year i'm not sure
how he will be able to get any writing
done this year when you consider how
many different things he is working on
you're about to find that out in a
minute once i go over the rest of this
update now hopefully the wins of winter
isn't the only thing that you're waiting
on as much as i want the winds of winter
i'm still very excited about everything
else that he's developing with hbo
so if the winds of winter is the only
thing you want unfortunately you will
have to keep waiting and waiting now if
you're like me and you're still
interested in the new shows and the
other novels based on his a song of ice
and fire universe then you have a lot of
exciting things to look forward to now
let me show you some of the great news
he shared with us he goes on to say in
addition to wins i also need to deliver
the second volume of archmaester
gildane's history fire and blood i'm
thinking and aiming that one blood and
fire rather than just the second volume
of fire and blood i do have a couple
hundred pages of that one written
already but there's still a long way to
go i also need to write more of the
duncan egg novellas especially since
there's a television series about them
in development there's a lavish coffee
table book coming later this year an
illustrated condensed version of fire
and blood done with ilio and linda who
also helped him write the world of ice
and fire and my fever river art director
rhea golden and another book after that
a who's who in westeros and that's just
the books there are also the successor
shows those have taken a ton of my time
and attention this year now i have seen
some comments out there wondering how
much i am involved in these new series
the answer is a lot deeply heavily
involved in every one of the new shows
and while i have been working closely
with some of the fantastic writers and
showrunners ultimately it is up to me to
try to keep the canon and to do all that
i can to help make the new shows great
and i love these stories alright now for
me this was some of the most exciting
news he shared in this massive update we
now have even further confirmation that
george rr martin is heavily involved
with the new shows as you all know this
is something a lot of us have been
worried about i know i've expressed this
myself i was wondering if he was
actually a co-creator on house of the
dragon or if they were only using his
name to help sell the show well it
doesn't really look like i have to worry
about that anymore he's letting us know
that he is helping them as much as he
can now what i like most about what he
said is he's making sure the writers and
showrunners follow his canon hopefully
that means they will adapt every word
that is written instead of making things
up on their own like we saw on game of
thrones with david and dan now they will
have to invent some things on house of
the dragon because it's not a fully
fleshed out story like a game of thrones
was in a song of ice and fire
unfortunately george hasn't written
anywhere near as much about the dance of
dragons but hopefully they will be
adapting every single thing he has
written about that era in westerosi
history alright so let's get back to
what he said in the update
he also says so far i am very excited
house of the dragon has wrapped in
london and is now in post-production
what i have seen i have loved i am eager
to see more i am excited about the other
successor shows as well however i am
dying to tell you about them but i'm not
supposed to
well maybe there are a few things i can
say
things that hbo announced before or at
least hinted at we are developing live
action shows for hbo
and animated shows for hbo max no i
can't tell you how many but it is my
hope that a number of these shows will
get on the air
not all no it's never all but more than
one now some of the ideas we are working
on are quite different in tone in
approach than what has gone before and
that thrills me the world of westeros
and essos is massive and there is room
in it for many different stories about a
wide range of characters now what can i
tell you well let's see bruno heller the
creator and showrunner of rome is
writing his script for the coreless
velaryon series that one started out as
nine voyages but we're now naming it the
sea snake since we wanted to avoid
having several shows with numbers in the
title the other one being ten thousand
ships the series about nymeria amanda
siegel our showrunner has developed a
couple drafts of that one and we are
forging ahead the third of the
live-action shows is dunkin egg helmed
by steve conrad my team and i have had
some great sessions with steve and his
team and we really hit it off he's
determined to do a faithful adaptation
of the stories which is exactly what i
want
these characters and stories are very
special to me the first season will be
an adaptation of the first novella the
hedge knight contrary to what you may
have read online the shows will not be
called dunkin egg which could be
mistaken for a sitcom by viewers
unfamiliar with these stories we're
leaning to naming it a night of the
seven kingdoms for the series title
though the hedge knight has its
partisans as well now over on the
animated side well i'm not allowed to
talk about most of what's happening
except to say that things are moving
very fast and i love love love some of
the concept art that i'm seeing and wait
come to think of it the news has already
leaked several months ago that one of
the animated shows would be set in yiti
that's true
our working title for that show is the
golden empire and we have a great young
writer on that one too and i think the
art and animation is going to be
beautiful i would say more if i could i
don't think i can say a word about the
other animated shows not yet
so there is lots going on and house of
the dragon is coming soon that's what
you will see first and me i will
continue to work with the writers and
show runners and directors on all these
new shows and in addition to all that
let me say one again yes i am working on
the winds of winter well there you have
it ladies and gentlemen there was a lot
of information in this announcement some
of it were things that we have heard
before but there is some very exciting
news in here as well we will
unfortunately have to wait a little
longer for the winds of winter
it's hard to know exactly how often he
is writing that novel when he has so
much other work on schedule that's why i
think all of you should start getting
interested in some of the other things
he is developing it will help make the
days go by as we wait for the end of a
song of ice and fire now as much as i
want the winds of winter right now i'm
still happy that he's helping create
these other shows i also love to hear
that he's making sure they follow his
canon hopefully that means hbo and their
writers will actually learn from the
mistakes that were made on game of
thrones as you can see there is a lot to
discuss so leave me some of your
thoughts down below
what has you excited the most other than
the winds of winter and house of the
dragon of course what show would you
like to see made after house of the
dragon i think it's dunkin egg for me
but like i always say i'm open to just
about anything so long as it's good now
before i go i want to thank all of you
for watching the video i hope everyone
has a great day i will see you in the
next one bye
[Music]
do
you